THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR FRIDAY
FEBRUARY TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO
IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER PLEASE
ADVISE ON AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS
BE MADE IS ALSO BEING TELEVISED
. WAS THE PUBLIC ATTENDANCE
TERMASUK MASS AT ALL TO.
ATTENDEES MUST ALSO REFRAIN FROM
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING.
VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES MAY
SUBJECT IN AN INDIVIDUAL FOR
MOBILE OR OTHER FORCE OUR
PROCESS. MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL COOLEY HERE
CUNNINGHAM BENNETT. BONTA FLORA
GIPSON HERE LEE MANGE. MATHIS
RAMOS. RUBIO. YOU ARE HERE WE
HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE A WE A
CONCERN AGENDA IS OUR EXAM
GENDER. MOVED BY MY ESCHBACH IS
SET RESERVE SECONDED BY MR
GIPSON RESPECT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. COOLEY HI COOLEY I CAN.
SENATE BENNETT I BONTA BONTA
HIGH FLOOR. FLORA I GIPSON GIVE
HIGHLY MAIN. MAIN AYE MATHIS
RAMA. AMONG I RUBIO RUBIO FIVE
COULD RUN I THE APPROVED ONE
FIVE MY PASSES MORE PASSED A LAW
THANK YOU ALL. WE WERE ALMOST
HER FOR MOMENTS OF THE QUALITY
FROM THANK VERY MUCH. ZERO ON
THE FLOOR. YES FORGET THE TO SEE
A MEDIA YEAH.
WE HAVE A CONSENT
AGENDA ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE. WE I. YEAH THAT MEASURE OF PAST
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITHIN THE
RULES PLACES ARE.